oui j'y repense mais sans trop y
repenser dire que forcément en fait
c'est un impact sur tout le reste et sur
la portée de mon message des cathédrales
aujourd'hui donc j'évite d'y repenser
tout en étant forcé ni repenser vous
pensez à quoi justement quand cette
épisode revient dans votre esprit je
repense
à la chance que j'ai eu de pas y passer
et surtout j'ai encore un
petit frisson forcément en pensant à
tous ces enfants qui heureusement s'en
sont sortis si vous deviez retenir une
émotion que vous avez ressenti peut-être
le 8 juin ou dans les jours qui ont
suivi laquelle serait-elle
c'est la on va dire la violence du
déferlement médiatique parce que je
pense que c'est peut-être ça qui était
le plus dur et à vrai dire au début je
ne voulais pas témoigner j'acceptais de
témoigner justement parce que je pensais
qu'il y avait un message plus fort que
moi à faire passer un message qui nous
dépasse tous en réalité et je pense que
je n'étais pas là parfaitement par
hasard quand j'ai croisé la route de ce
type parce que j'étais sur le chemin des
cathédrales dans une démarche de
pèlerinage je suis encore dans une
démarche pèlerinage parce que là je suis
de passage très rapidement entre deux
cathédrales mais donc voilà j'ai jugé
que c'était le moment de de dire faire
passer un message d'espérance à vrai
dire
aux Français sur la beauté de nos
cathédrales et en fait le fait de
relever la tête d'arrêter de vouloir
subir le mal et de et de de s'inspirer
du grand et du beau pour agir en
conséquence donc voilà vous avez été
surpris par ce déferlement médiatique
qui a suivi cet épisode oui à vrai dire
on sait on sait que ça arrive mais on ne
sait jamais à quoi à quoi s'attendre et
on est toujours surpris en conf
effectivement en fait c'est sa vie
privée qui est déballée du jour au
lendemain au grand jour à la face du
monde et c'est pas que soient ces ses
amis sa famille qui qui sont exposés
donc vous recevez à ce moment-là des
dizaines et des dizaines de demandes
d'interview par des médias français des
médias à l'international comment vous
avez géré tout cela j'ai géré en me en
ayant qu'une idée fixe dans la tête
c'est à dire réorienter le débat sur
l'essentiel sur ce que jugé être
l'essentiel c'est à dire un message de
beauté parce que on sort de ce genre
d'événements tragique que par le haut et
pour moi le haut c'était les flèches des
cathédrales j'étais en fait ça faisait
deux mois et demi au moment des faits
maintenant ça fait plus ça fait 6 mois
mais au moment des faits ça faisait deux
mois et demi que je me nourrissais de
rencontre incroyable le long du chemin
que que je me nourrissais de la beauté
de ces édifices religieux et c'était ma
manière à moi de sortir par le beau et
c'est le message que j'ai voulu faire
passer est-ce que vous avez eu peur que
cette nouvelle notoriété vous empêche de
reprendre une vie normale
est-ce que j'en ai eu peur je ne crois
pas en tout cas il a fallu composer avec
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai de la chance d'avoir
une audience par rapport au cathédrales
mais le seul message que sur lequel
j'insiste c'est que les gens de me
suivent pas pour moi les gens me suivent
pour justement la démarche que je suis
en train de faire et pour la beauté que
j'essaye de transmettre pourquoi
dites-vous justement que vous n'étiez
pas là par hasard
mais en fait si on prend un peu de recul
c'est très symbolique ce qui s'est passé
il y a un demandeur d'asile syrien avec
une vie terrible qui croise qui au
moment où il vrille et il veut passer à
l'acte croise le et il passe à l'acte
croise le chemin d'un d'un vrai
catholique qui essaye de vivre une
démarche pèlerinage intérieure et qui se
nourrit de ce que les ancêtres de ce que
ces ancêtres lui ont légué à savoir les
cathédrales en France et donc on a une
espèce de de vision du monde qui
s'affrontent en réalité vous parlez vous
faites référence ouvertement votre foi
catholique vous êtes catholique
pratiquant dans quelle mesure c'est
quelque chose qui a joué qui a pesé dans
votre discernement au moment où vous
êtes interposé contre cet homme écoutez
c'est vrai que j'ai la foi la foi qu'est
ce que c'est c'est une rencontre intime
avec le Christ le Christ qui a donné sa
vie pour les hommes donc si vraiment on
est quelque chose que vous avez à
laquelle vous avez pensé à ce moment-là
le non j'ai pas pensé ça m'a nourri
puisque en fait je grandis avec depuis
le début les deux les on va dire les
deux idées fixes que vous avez en tête
au moment de l'action c'était Arnaud
Beltrame et Saint-Michel qu'est-ce qui a
changé entre le Henry d'avant et le
Henri d'après cet épisode il a pas
changé
le Henri n'a pas changé il reste dans sa
démarche de pèlerinage des cathédrales
et ça reste un jeune garçon qui essaye
de comprendre son époque et de
s'inscrire dedans et à faire passer un
message de beauté il a pas changé c'est
plus les moyens qui ont changé en
revanche les moyens qui ont changé parce
que vous avez été érigé en une sorte de
de héros national comme ça du jour au
lendemain vous personnellement est-ce
que vous comprenez que l'on puisse
considérer que vous êtes un héros ou
bien est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui
vous gêne c'est quelque chose qui m'a
énormément gêné pourquoi parce que je
pense avoir fait ce que chacun aurait dû
ou devrait faire
et donc si vous voulez autrefois on
érigé en héros des personnes qui avaient
bravé le destin sur des vies entières
traversées des océans ni leur vie en
danger pour des choses
extrêmement belles et importantes j'ai
juste eu l'impression d'avoir fait mon
devoir en réalité de chrétien et de
français mais comment est-ce que vous
avez survé comment vous vivez cela en
fait d'être érigé comme ça en héros
national du jour au lendemain
il faut c'est difficile
c'est voyez votre tête sur tous les
journaux en fait si vous voulez en fait
si vous voulez je j'accepte le statut
parce que justement je me suis mis
moi-même au service d'un message qui me
dépasse donc en réalité j'ai
l'impression que le statut qui m'est
donné me dépasse aussi et donc tant
mieux si c'est inspire les gens et c'est
ce que je recherche c'est effectivement
d'inspirer les gens
à travers
les cathédrales que je montre mais et la
Providence a voulu que ce soit aussi à
travers un acte qui peut-être m'a
dépassé aussi sur le moment mais donc
oui il faut c'est
si ça inspire les gens tant mieux et ça
me rend ça me ça me rend heureux est-ce
que vous êtes encore en contact
aujourd'hui avec les familles des
victimes non j'aimerais bien mais non
vous aimeriez bien pourquoi c'est pas
possible j'ai perdu leur contact
en tout cas vous avez rencontré le
président de la République dans les
jours qui ont suivi ces événements et
vous a même décoré la Légion d'honneur
dans la promotion du 14 juillet comment
est-ce que vous avez reçu cette
récompense
alors j'ai été nommé au Journal officiel
mais je n'ai pas encore reçu alors mais
c'est que malgré tout une récompense
comment vous l'avez vécu
bah écoutez comme je disais tout à
l'heure c'est
je continue de penser que je la mérite
pas qu'il y a des gens qui offrent qui
ont une vie de sacrifices entières pour
la France et pour leur et pour les
Français qui la méritent beaucoup plus
que moi mais je l'accepte parce que déjà
l'ont demandé pour moi et je l'accepte
aussi pour sa portée symbolique c'est
vrai qu'Emmanuel Macron vous a promis
que vous pourriez assister à la
réouverture de Notre-Dame de Paris
le lendemain de l'attaque à la
sous-préfecture d'Annecy j'ai fait cette
demande de pouvoir assister à
l'université d'être en train de Paris
parce que c'est pour moi très symbolique
et il m'en a fait la promesse j'en suis
très heureux et c'est vrai que ça va
être un moment très fort et d'ailleurs
j'invite les Français à se rendre compte
du Trésor qu'on a entre les mains c'est
à dire de enfin on va on va redécouvrir
une cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris comme
jamais dit générations avant nous n'ont
plus la découvrir et la voir donc le
travail qu'ils font est absolument
merveilleux il faut vraiment en avoir
conscience donc je suis extrêmement
honoré et même ému en avance de pouvoir
assister à une telle cérémonie je vous
lis quelques messages qui nous arrivent
sur le dans le chat sur Le Figaro.fr ce
jeune homme devrait être un exemple que
pour beaucoup félicitations aux parents
nous dit un autre internaute qui l'ont
éduqué et qui de est et pardon qui ont
fait qu'il est comme il est aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que par ce geste vous avez
inspiré des milliers des milliers de
gens qui ont été touchés par cette
bravoure par ce courage quel est le
message que vous entendez porté
aujourd'hui ah mais ça je d'espérance un
message d'espérance je sais toujours le
même message c'est dire regarder la le
lac de nos ancêtres levez la tête
regardez les flèches et cathédrales
rentrer dans les cathédrales regarder
les merveilles d'architecture d'art
d'histoire de spiritualité il faut s'en
nourrir et c'est que en se nourrissant
de ce genre de beauté intemporel on
s'inscrit dans le temps long qu'on va
pouvoir
retrouver une certaine grandeur
personnelle et une grandeur pour le pays
et vous avez donc repris ce chemin des
cathédrales ou en êtes-vous dans votre
périple alors j'arrive de Luçon en
Vendée et je repars demain pour lui son
parce que ce soir je suis spécialement à
Paris pour donner un témoignage ce soir
au Cirque d'Hiver à l'occasion de la
grande soirée des éveilleurs et quelles
sont les prochaines étapes jusqu'à quand
va se dérouler ce tour des cathédrales
que l'on peut suivre d'ailleurs vous
êtes très présent sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment sur votre compte
Instagram jusqu'où et bien allez-vous
aller alors j'ai commencé le 25 mars et
je finis le 24 décembre quels sont ça
fait pile 9 mois et quels sont les
étapes à venir pour les étapes à venir
et bien écoutez c'est le sud Vendée donc
la Rochelle maïzet parce que il y a ils
étaient une ancienne cathédrale Vendée
et puis je vais continuer à descendre
jusque dans les Pyrénées longer les
Pyrénées et remonter en région
parisienne par le Massif Central vous
sauriez me dire là combien visité
jusqu'à présent à peu près 95 et il en
reste combien à peu près 60 ça fait
encore ça fait encore beaucoup
d'édifice est-ce que vous diriez que ce
que ce tour des cathédrales vous a
changé
c'est trop tôt pour le dire je me
rendrais compte plus tard ça en tout cas
c'est un projet très atypique pourquoi
avoir décidé de vous lancer dans cette
aventure au mois de mars dernier en fait
c'est un rêve de gosse j'ai envie de
dire c'est un rêve de lycéen ça fait
longtemps que vous y pensiez ça fait 7
ans que j'y pense c'est un rêve de
lycéens et puis après j'étais très
marqué par l'incendie notre homme de
Paris où je me suis dit qu'il y avait un
hommage à rendre un autre cathédrales et
puis rappeler qu'il n'y a pas que notre
âme de Paris que le patrimoine religion
français le patrimoine le plus menacé et
que à travers ces cathédrales qui
ressent un peu le symbole qui sont
plutôt bien traités il y a derrière tout
un tas de chapelles et d'églises qui
souffrent c'est aussi une volonté de
transmettre de transmettre un message
une beauté et bah d'inspirer un maximum
de personnes qui veulent bien me suivre
qu'est-ce qui vous touche finalement
dans ces cathédrales que vous visitez
jour après jour quand on rentre dans une
cathédrale c'est simple les quatre
erreurs ont été construits pour deux
choses par nos ancêtres ils ont été
construites un pour les générations
futures
et elles ont été construites pour le bon
Dieu donc quand tu rentres dans une
cathédrale moi ce qui me touche c'est ce
qu'il y a au centre de la cathédrale ce
qui a sur le tel dans le tabernacle vous
auriez pu vous lancer dans un tour de
France peut-être même dans le domaine
religieux mais d'autres choses de d'un
certain nombre de monastères d'un
certain nombre d'église pourquoi
pourquoi les cathédrales alors j'inclus
quand même quelques monastères quelques
habits dans mon parcours quand il est
quand elles sont sur le chemin mais
pourquoi les cathédrales parce que en
réalité c'est il y en a partout il y en
a dans toutes les moyennes villes les
grosses villes de France on a une
histoire très riche en termes de diocèse
une cathédrale c'est le siège d'un
diocèse c'est là où siège un évêque le
mot cathédrale vient du la cathédra qui
est le siège de l'évêque donc en fait si
vous voulez c'est très territorial il y
a des cathédrales partout en France et
chacun est très fier de sa propre
cathédrale donc c'est une manière pour
moi de visiter le pays voyage à travers
le pays découvrir ces différentes
régions ces différentes mentalités c'est
1000 facettes au travers de d'espèces de
repères spatio-temporel qui unifie
l'ensemble du territoire que sont les
cathédrales et les choses ont fait que
vous êtes retrouvés donc en première
ligne si je puis dire à Annecy le 8 juin
dernier est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
moments d'autres épisodes de rencontres
que vous avez fait et qui vous ont
particulièrement marqué au cours de ce
périple oui énormément de rencontres
énormément de rencontres très belles et
peut-être une des plus belles rencontres
pour donner une anecdote comme ça
c'était lorsque j'ai j'arrive à la
symbole c'était avant une scie donc je
n'avais pas encore tout le côté
célébrité que je peux avoir aujourd'hui
donc la Sainte Baume pour nous pour
noter les spectateurs c'est en Provence
et c'est l'île de la France c'est une
grotte dans laquelle il est morte et a
vécu Sainte-Marie Madeleine donc il a
connu le Christ et lorsqu'elle est
arrivée en France pour évangéliser et en
fait j'ai rencontré une vieille
québécoise qui jouait du du de
l'harmonica sur le bord de la route et
j'avais un harmonica dans le sac je ne
savais pas en jouer et je lui ai demandé
de m'apprendre à en jouer on a joué à
deux comme ça sur le bord de la route de
l'harmonica c'est complètement spontané
on connaissait même pas nos prénoms et
ça c'était avant Annecy oui mais encore
aujourd'hui je fais de très très belles
rencontres j'en aurai des milliers à
raconter mais le fait que vous ayez et
bien réalisé contact à Annecy ça a
forcément changé quelque chose également
dans le regard qu'on les gens que vous
rencontrez effectivement ça a été
difficile à accepter ça aussi mais en
fait je me rends compte que pour moi
c'est une superbe occasion de d'engager
la conversation et tout de suite aussi
rapidement sur des choses profondes et
la conversation en tout cas vous
l'engagez également avec tous ces
internautes qui vous qui vous suivent
sur vos réseaux sociaux qui ont qui ont
quadruplé peut-être car tu plais même
peut-être plus depuis ce qui s'est passé
à si vous êtes je crois à 130 000
abonnés aujourd'hui sur votre compte
Instagram pourquoi c'est important pour
vous de témoigner
parce que ce trésor ne m'appartient pas
qu'à moi c'est pas parce que j'y goote
personnellement que les autres ne
doivent pas y goûter tout le monde n'a
pas la chance comme moi d'avoir soit la
forme physique soit le temps ou la folie
peut-être de faire ce genre de
d'aventure de périple donc si je le fais
c'est pas que pour moi il faut que je le
partage parce que c'est un trésor commun
et cette passion en tout cas pour le
patrimoine c'est quelque chose que vous
allez continuer continuer pardon
d'entretenir à la fin de ce périple
c'est quelque chose qui me nourrira
toute ma vie c'est certain
on verra bien vous savez pas encore ce
que vous allez faire montrer à la fin de
je laisse les portes ouvertes à la
Providence merci beaucoup en tout cas en
ride merci d'avoir été avec nous dans
dans le point de vue bien sûr on vous
souhaite et bien une bonne suite dans
votre périple à travers les 7 France des
des cathédrales merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous dans le point de vue
aujourd'hui